when people ask me what i do i kind of
sigh because it's like oh god how do i
explain this
i found the easiest myth is to say i
make these machines you know like a ball
rolls and hits some dominoes and it
pulls a string and it might turn the
page of a newspaper via a long chain
reaction using everyday objects and then
they're just immediately like oh yeah i
got it i got it
i'm joseph herscher and i make rube
goldberg machines
[Music]
a rube goldberg machine it's a machine
that does a simple task in an overly
complicated way rube goldberg was
actually a cartoonist and he used to
draw these elaborate machines he was
very popular in his time and the term
rube goldberg has come to be used to
describe any kind of overly complicated
mechanism
we all kind of recognize these machines
because we've seen them throughout
cinema and television like pee-wee's big
adventure they have one at the start
wallace and gromit is one of my
favorites there's one in chitty chitty
bang bang
all the game mouse traps everybody loves
that game the funnest part is just doing
the machine no one actually cares about
the board game itself
i made my first machine when i was five
years old i was a machine for storing my
candy obviously very useful for a
five-year-old but i also noticed it made
my parents smile and that's kind of what
spurred me on to keep making elaborate
devices
i lost interest for a good few years
while i was a teenager but when i was 22
i discovered these really great japanese
machines from a kids tv show
my roommates and i got really inspired
and we started building this contraption
for me it reworked my childhood passion
and i kept building and building and
building and that was the beginning of
my new career as a professional useless
machine builder from joseph's machines
on youtube please welcome joseph
hirscher joseph
since that first homemade machine slowly
my machines have got more and more
elaborate one of the hardest things i've
ever done was a live demonstration on
jimmy kimmel
that was so nerve-wracking because these
machines they don't work every time but
they have to when you're on live
television
i made a machine at the venice biennale
that pours water into a plant i had an
appearance on sesame street hello
i've made many feeding machines i've
made a machine to
stuff a turkey
a sunscreen dispenser
a way to lick stamps without having to
actually taste them
the biggest machine i've created
was in a huge postal factory it used 30
slides that were five stories high
and it was a machine that slid me into
bed
it usually takes one to three months to
build a machine it's a lot of trial and
error and it's learning through
observation so i'm watching and seeing
how things fail and seeing how they fail
is really important because that teaches
me
how to tweak it
i want a certain amount of risk built in
if i play it too safe and they work
every time then it's going to be a
boring machine but if you've got like
asparagus flying through the air that's
being caught in my mouth then that's
miraculous when it works
people often ask do you calculate like
the physics behind them and work out how
things are going to go no way that's so
hard can you imagine calculating
everything based on the exact angle and
air flow like it would be impossible
there's too much chaos at this small
scale it's much faster to just grab a
ball and roll it and see where it hits
there is a myriad of ways that i go
about creating things let's say i'm i'm
trying to connect a to b and i have no
idea how to connect it well i'll think
what's the theme here let's say it's a
dinner machine so what's some fun dinner
objects that i feel like working with
butter sounds fun and maybe candles
because they can like melt the butter
and i allow myself this time to just
play
and then just see what i discover and
what makes me laugh what interests me
they discovered this amazing thing where
if you put butter on a strip of metal
with a candle under it it'll slide down
really slowly in this kind of crazy way
that ended up being people's favorite
part of that machine even though it was
never part of the plan i was just trying
to get from a to b ultimately
i pour so much love into everything that
i build
that i really care about it working and
so i'm just like on the edge of my seat
willing it to work and on the 85th take
you suddenly get it and it's this
magical moment
[Music]
[Applause]
i think ultimately i love the fact that
there's this potential for magic and
delight and play in the everyday world
around us and i think that's what people
enjoy watching these machines as well
it's this kind of nice
moment where everything kind of just
fits and connects
and the universe feels less
arbitrary maybe and making these
connections gives me a wonderful sense
of like peace
you